you've never gone skinny-dipping I'm
very insecure we're going right now but
I think there's an acorn hiding your
cubes shut up I said skinny-dipping huh
mini dippin I should have just gone
straight to New York to start my new job
come on man he's your dad all right you
can handle this does he live down there
[Music]
hey Dad are you [ __ ] I didn't bring a
bathing suit problem solved till you
girls
chuckling yes hi
oh my god what's up guy that guy came
over here and tried to fight you what
would you do that kind of marine I would
take my beating like a true American who
would you fight I'd totally fight your
death before this when my dad looks like
a human Muppet and I'm a hunter
accenture he could kick your dad's s
what do you think would win he's a lot
bigger than you
he'd probably be sober which is a huge
plus do you know how many fights I've
been in I don't know six seven if you
count that little dust-up I had to use
call my kids lost all [ __ ] there's a
storm brewing on Maple Street I'm here
to settle this debate I kids that
haven't weather what's the debate we
don't really care about you guys
fighting I think you do you got five
seconds to swing no I got three
and that gazelle fleet
[Music]
where is that [ __ ] how come
you're not in New York I bodyslam my dad
off a roof Joey yeah and then they
arrested US you know with your one phone
call last night you called me and I lost
my job
so you'll draw up the charges get me a
fool I'll drop the charges
how about a birdbath why I don't have
any [ __ ] Birds
I [ __ ] up his life pretty bad I got to
make it right I just got us a meeting it
is G we're getting you job back what are
you doing I'm gonna make this right for
you what no this is our VR meeting space
not real everybody now Pelican
some people say I'm unstable and I snap
my god
that was a snap
you